some say the zeros are still going hey
what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 26 of network chat
programming so today we're gonna cover
one of the vulnerabilities that I talked
about last time and that was the fact
that some occasionally you know things
wouldn't really work according to plan
okay so in other words if we start up
our server here using a server man of
course we start that up start that puppy
up and we um we go ahead and actually
you know what before us before I do that
let's just get rid of this in in the
manage here whoops come on in manage
clients over here we'll get rid of this
system that I have to print line clients
out sighs clear that clear that out
console there as well and we'll start
our server man real quick started great
we'll start logging in real quick as
well and what we'll do is we'll login on
localhost I want to log in and then you
can see we've logged in here but what
happens is if we sense if we prefix
something with a slash em slash and then
we go send whatever you can see it's not
gonna work okay and the reason that's
not going to work is because /m slash is
kind of a big deal to us it's kind of
the character it's kind of the well okay
I'll go over what actually happens if we
go into server just so you guys can
understand I guess that is the whole
point of this series anyway what happens
is when we look at this right when we
look at the string starts with M right
what happens is in the center all we are
oh well okay looks like it's a client
thing but if we go into client so what
happens is again we send the entire
message we actually don't even modify
the what the message is so in other
words what we've gone is we've our
current message right was /m slash and
then of course another /m slash because
we put a slash em slash and then the
actual the actual program puts another
/m slash here right so what happens is
we've got two now and we say something
like hey and then what happens is of
course it prefix it post fixes an a here
as well in between false lashes this is
now sent to the client okay and once the
client gets that whoops once the client
gets that what client does is in the
receive
let's say so we return the message so
whatever we do that before we print it
to the console essentially that it's
what client window does so let's find
the receive in here real quick spelt
that wrong receive okay it's the clients
that receive
so if message to us with M what we do
here is we get the message which is that
and we go ahead and we split it using
the using the M or the e expression here
right so what that does is it gets rid
of that and gets rid of this but what
happens is you can see we select the
first index so what it does is it
because it gets it clears that and it
clears that it actually selects the
space in between the two M's right
because they're both rejecters and what
happens is um well what happens
essentially is right everything here is
marked zero
everything here is marked one everything
here which is this entire hey thing is
marked two and then everything here is
marked index three in that array okay
so what happens is now instead of us
being one which is what we usually are
because if there's no M then essentially
this is what happens right if there's no
M this is what happens and one is
actually our message we kind of get get
left without any message and that's a
problem so to fix that it's pretty
simple right all will do it will kind of
forbid I guess the that's what it says
it will just we won't allow the user to
send em okay we'll just make sure that
is something that's not allowed to be
sent okay
and I mean you you could work around it
but really how often is that gonna
happen it's we're gonna be some kind of
mistake
if they really want to send it I guess
you could maybe do it halfway through
but that the reason is that because
we're using it to kind of delimit it
there's no real way to solve this that
will actually work okay so what we want
to do well actually you know what I
don't want to say it that way because
there is that's actually some okay let's
go back into our client window and then
what we'll do over here is instead of
saying
in the em stuff so let's go over here
yeah there's a probably a better way to
fix this than what I'm thinking right
now this is gonna be some improvisation
here instead of splitting this by slash
and we'll make sure it starts with them
right I don't always we'll we'll get rid
of this and we'll owners put it by E but
what we'll do is we'll also go ahead and
do first of all message dot I think
there's a let's say substring right I
think the beginning Dex that is
specified in this any sense okay
so we'll grab that and we'll just put
three here okay and then we'll put a dot
message squid okay so maybe that's not
working
hang on that I'll just say okay so we'll
get rid of message okay so we get the
substring of it and then we split it
okay so at index 3 we have of course if
we preview this we've got index 0 index
1 index 2 and then index 3 so I think
it'll keep that in there we'll test it
out in a minute but this should now work
okay so if we go back to our server and
think we're running that and I went up
we launch that based will actually
launch login we type in showing our
localhost oops
make sure you spell that right 8 1 9 to
login if we try and send something like
slow let's just try some sense on like
hey okay that crashes why does that
crash alright next out-of-bounds
oh yeah okay so this now needs to be 0
and just for some safety here let's do
this okay let's run that again we don't
need to do anything with this over here
server is still running sure no
localhost ant 190 login we will say hey
ok yeah that works perfectly so if we
now go a / m / m / hey
bro I totally schooled your system hope
you guys can see that so yeah we do that
we prefix it with a /m we send it you
can see it still appears here and
everything did not break our system so
yeah that message was substring is
pretty much how we can avoid that entire
kind of debate on on how to do that so
anyway that's gonna wrap up this episode
I've never shot programming hope you
guys did enjoy it if you did please hit
the like button and next time we're
gonna take a look at I guess clients dis
disconnecting kind of abnormally right
so if the client disconnects and and he
kind of shouldn't have or he didn't do
it cleanly he didn't press the exit
button
the client was terminated for some
reason then the server needs to also
deal with that kind of thing so I'll see
you guys next time goodbye